hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of alexa and friends my name is
jeff blankenberg and today i have
yashadrapo
who is a senior scientist on the alexa
ai team yasha thank you so much for
being here today
it's my pleasure jeff so one of the
things that i like to do when we start
these interviews is ask a couple of uh
what i've referred to as silly questions
and i have not prepared you for these
you didn't know these were on the the
list of things we might talk about today
uh but the first one that i like to ask
people about is
related to uh superpowers and
superheroes um oftentimes you know we've
seen many many movies over the past 10
or 12 years about superheroes and all
the cool things that they superpowers
that they have
and i'm always interested to know from
our guests
what you would pick if you could pick a
superpower for yourself amongst all the
ones you've ever seen in comic books or
movies
what is something that appeals to you as
a superpower
that
is a
fantastic question
uh there's you know there's all these uh
superhero movies are the thing now it
seems like we go through cycles of
uh you know zombies being big and then
vampires and then uh superheroes maybe
we're we're due for another zombie
apocalypse in the in the theaters
um
i always you know i'm gonna go with the
classic here superman
uh because you know superman can fly you
know it started out as leaping then he's
flying and
then he can do stuff with his eyes and
you know
and it's really the the superhero that's
been around for a long time this power
seemed to really grow over time yeah
and so it's really hard to um
uh to pigeonhole it
um and the thing the thing i really love
about superman is he can he can protect
himself
and he's very strong so all the tension
in his stories come from
um uh threats to the people that he
loves the people around him and the
earth and the planet and how does he
reconcile being so all-powerful but then
still being vulnerable and so right that
that resonates with me my son's gonna my
son's gonna be upset with me because
um he is not a fan of dc comics no he's
a marvel guy he's a marvel guy
that's right so what i generally do here
though is i pin people down uh
we can live in the superman world if you
want to but if you can only pick one of
his powers or one of anyone's powers
rather than being the superhero
themselves you only get to pick one
powerful
power
that's harder
that is harder um
i don't know super speed would be really
fun
uh i think so that's very good
that's something that comes up quite
often i think because people always feel
strapped for time um yeah but it's it's
almost a sort of time travel in the way
that it's portrayed uh in movies right
they can slow things down so much
that they're able to take advantage of
turning a second into a minute or an
hour
that's right well that's more of a flash
power actually i think yeah but superman
and flash i guess they fought in in in
some of the dc
um
uh dc products but the
yeah yeah time travel does come into it
in the original superman the motion
picture with uh christopher reeve uh he
does kind of i guess rewind the planet
um
i don't think that's how
the rotation of the earth works but he
did it
yeah
yeah super speed is fun all right so uh
thank you for that uh the second one is
super fast uh but it's a question that
we probably will never get rid of on
this show because people seem to enjoy
it so
i want you to imagine for a moment
you're walking through a large city big
city blocks big buildings everywhere and
you need to get one street over you're
on 17th street you need to get to 18th
street
uh and you can see that there's an alley
that'll give you easy access to make
that walk from the street you're on to
the streets you need to get to without
walking all the way around that big city
block
it's safe it's daylight there's no
reason to think that this is an unsafe
alley so you decide to head down that
alley towards the place that you're
going uh and as you get about halfway
there you notice at the end that you're
heading towards
emerges a giant horse-sized duck
big duck
at the other end
as you turn around to retreat from this
perceived threat
you find 100
duck-sized horses
very very small horses yeah
my question for you and for everybody
that's been on the show is
which direction would you go knowing
that you now need to find your way out
of this alley what do you feel is the
and you will have the most success at
exiting right
so
um lucky for me i i've been on the
internet long enough that that i have i
have encountered this question this uh
paradox or dilemma this dilemma before
and i've given it some thought
and what you have to do is you have to
go to the core nature of the animal
and horses are just like
big puppies right um people keep them as
pets they they pet them they're nice
sometimes they make questionable
decisions but overall they're big
mammals they look like they they act
like puppies
ducks however are
mean sobs
not known for their for their great
demeanor you know if you said duckling
you know maybe but but if a duck
horse-sized duck is not for me
i'm going to the end with the hundred
puppy-sized horses all right
that is that is some solid reasoning
i've heard many definitions about how
people would choose to go one way or the
other
yours is well thought out i like that
thank you um all right so
let's let's skip beyond the silly
because i really want to get to know you
and kind of your history and some of the
things that you're working on so one of
the things that i we generally start the
interview with once we've gotten past
that previous nonsense
is
uh your background where did you come
from where did you go to school um what
were the decisions you made along the
way what does your career path look like
i'd love to hear that you know that five
or seven minute story about
where you went and what kind of projects
you were interested in and
uh how you landed where you are today
yeah i i owe a lot of where i am today
to kind of the
um the whole uh
you know
computer culture in in the 70s and 80s
and the fact that my parents were
involved in it i mean my dad
um so my earliest memories are him
building
uh wire wrap computers um in his study
and going to
you know uh the hanford
surplus sales
and getting things like teletypes if
you've never heard of a teletype that's
a
it's like a typewriter
but it's the size of
um a jukebox
and it sounds like a freight train when
it's going
and so before crts is the way you'd
communicate with computers it'd be
hacking it'd be hacking away and typing
and shaking and
um
and so that was that was great fun and
you know he would
uh mad libs were
this mad lib program is one of my
earliest memories he would show me how
to write a basic program
and it would you say
prompt like input a verb input a word
input a adjective
and then it would you know fill it in
and write out a little story
and so by the time i was four or five
years old i was able to you know modify
the code and put in different matte lips
and so he got me started on the um
on the programming
um i was also really uh fascinated with
um
the intersection of of what computers
and audio could do as as i grew up
um so i also want to mention the other
person who really got me into computing
was my mother who was a teacher at the
time and she
was taking classes on thing something
called logo
which is kind of a cross between
programming and graphics and
john crawford who you know 12 years
later would become my calculus teacher
taught me um
uh
well taught her logo but i was sitting
next to her so that i would help her
with her homework
um the programming program came in early
and then i got interested in the
intersection with computers and audio
i did things like um
uh grade school project on
text-to-speech synthesis chip where you
could set little dip switches to a
binary number representing one of the
words i could say and because the chip
was from a clock all i could say is like
numbers in am and pm
but it was pretty fun
um it built like an electronic drum kit
and then later i got in middle school i
got this book from the university of
washington called musical applications
of microprocessors which was fascinating
to me yeah i got into like sampling
music on my apple ii built a little
circuit
and
modified it and played it back and
um you know it was just great fun
um so i went to gra when i went to
college at gonzaga
i ended up studying electrical
engineering because that was the closest
thing to you know what i wanted to do
this was
just before gonzaga it was after
stockton but before gonzaga basketball
got really big
um so uh studying electrical engineering
there
and i
um
i i graduated and started working for a
printer company
um designing little
uh designing algorithms to drive the
printhead faster
and a friend of mine had applied to grad
school and i said i asked him you know
what is that he goes oh it's you get to
keep going to school and study something
deeply and
i a friend of mine
and i uh
so i just half-heartedly uh sent off a
application to university of washington
grad school
and by the time they accepted me
i had realized that designing printer
algorithms was isn't what i wanted to do
with my life
so i went to the university had no idea
what i was doing didn't know you needed
to you know have a lab to work with or
you could teach to help offset your
tuition
and i ended up with less atlas who was
big in signal processing he introduced
me to the folks over at microsoft
research
who got me into speech processing
and then i did a few internships there
ended up getting a job there when i
graduated worked there for nearly 20
years
working on advanced speech recognition
techniques through the
you know the advent of neural networks
and end-to-end models and and all and
gpu processing and all that
um and about two and a half years ago i
decided it was time for a change and i
looked for a place to land and
alexa and amazon is is what i chose
alexa stop
around here she's she who must not be
named uh and and so i've been working
here for two and a half years and
based on my background i'm comfortable
with everything speech and audio and so
i have my fingers in a lot of stuff
the easiest way to understand it is
anything that goes from speech
to a structured representation of that
speech and back again
that's something that i care deeply
about and have my have my fingers in
that's uh that's excellent so
um while yours is significantly longer
you and i have similar paths i
i spent nine of the early years of my
career at microsoft um
not not working in the research that you
were doing
uh but i spent a lot of my time uh in
whatever the latest and greatest
software development technologies were
yeah and uh i left there in
2015 uh just as alexa was kind of coming
online and
jumped over here to uh to join this team
and so it's been no looking back since
this is uh
absolutely incredible technology that
i'm
so happy that i get an opportunity to
work with on a daily basis
right
right yeah even before alexa came out
people were going to amazon that i knew
and i was i was thinking what the heck
is amazon doing with all these speech
scientists and computer scientists and
what could they possibly be building
um and it was it was shocking when it
came out i remember i remember some of
us in a room with one of the first
echoes and we put it on the table and we
used it then we stepped away and then we
started playing music and using it and
it was like how the heck did they do
this
such a surprising
development
yeah i would imagine especially for the
folks like you that are in that industry
um that are thinking deeply about a lot
of those problems that had to be like
wait this just got
very real
it did
that's uh that's great um all right so
you said you've you know for the last 21
years or so you've been working in the
tech industry and you've been focused on
as you said speech recognition signal
processing that kind of stuff
over that time what what are the things
that had the biggest impact sorry impact
on our progress uh
over the last couple of decades are
there anything that is there any like
advancements that you saw that kind of
stood out
right right so
a lot of people might lead off with um
machine learning and deep learning and
all the advances we have algorithmically
um and
and
and so on and so on
um but i think that
uh the very
uh bedrock what would allowed us to
start actually doing science on this
standardized data and evaluations
uh
starting in the late
mid to mid to late 90s
the the field started
operating on standardized data sets so
when you published people knew exactly
what data you're using they knew exactly
what results to get
and you could over time do better and
better
and without that kind of shared view of
the world it was it's difficult to make
process sure um
but nowadays you know when you have
things like interrupt yeah was there a
catalyst for that like was is that
exactly probably not typical in most
research fields
it was it was a government
so uh funding agencies like darpa and
iarpa
wanted to be able to score the labs that
were competing for grant money
and so they developed these standardized
data sets like switchboard and call home
um that were difficult and related to
what the technology they wanted to
develop
and then seeded the community with this
and so
after the evaluations happened
the field was able to still keep chewing
on the same data over time and driving
down the error rate
and so that was that that that that's a
really big deal um
having the data available and
um being able to directly compare
it's
it's um
it's kind of a no-brainer now because
it's a big thing to have these
competitions where you have leaderboards
online and everybody's working against
the same data and you publish your code
you can see exactly what they're doing
but back in the dark ages it wasn't
clear that that was the the right way to
go people um
it was that that's one of the
innovations that really enabled
speech recognition and then you know
machine learning in general to to make
leaps forward
that's that's awesome so okay so we we
talked a little bit about standardized
data is there anything else
so the other big thing especially for
speech recognition was standardized
recipes
um
when i was working with uh
dan
back in microsoft
uh he he created he conceptualized and
created this thing called kaldi
which is a toolkit for building speech
recognition systems
um and before that
most everybody was either using
homegrown software or something called
hdk
which was very difficult to put together
and people would describe
in broad terms how they processed the
standard data
and then you had to take their pros
and convert it into your own
software pipeline
from these from these available pieces
and no one is ever quite sure whether
you've got things exactly the same
whether you're comparing apples to
apples
but kaldi what it did was it created a
modern
framework c
framework
which was great and tooling
but then it also shipped with standard
recipes
so you could have a turnkey switchboard
system
and know exactly how it performed and
how it worked and so now when people
publish they could say i use kaldi
recipe
4b for switchboard
and
instead of the pros people would know
exactly what that was
and that
also started to allow us to use science
and iterate on each other's work because
there was there was more visibility into
exactly what we were doing and so those
are the two two pillars that over time
um are very general things the the
sharing of evaluations
and the sharing of the recipes i think
were were big needle movers
and was did caldi come out of a specific
project or group also or is that um
that's a good question
um
so kyle kylee started at microsoft
research
and it was a passion project of uh of
his
and he
spent i don't know maybe a year at
microsoft working at it and then uh
decided that he would be better served
if he went to hopkins
johns hopkins university and continued
his work there and so it got open
sourced and then most of the the
goodness of um
of that came from
uh his work at um
at johns hopkins and that's that's true
of a lot of
a lot of the individual threads of
things that made the field better they
were there were passion projects of
individuals um they it was something
that they believed in they believed that
the field needed
and
rather than going out and saying you
know to their manager
what what
what do you want me to do
what do you need it was more of trying
to find out where is the best place
that i can be to execute on my vision
uh that's awesome
and then then of course there's the the
other thing that really helped the field
was deep learning about 10 years ago
[Music]
it made the leap from kind of toy
systems on a small data set called
timit
to a large vocabulary system that showed
that neural networks can
can beat
the previous technology
and from there it was you know
from dnn hybrid systems to
ctc that the graves invented which was
better for
recurrent models now um their current
models are better
and then integrating language modeling
and then today
we figured the field as a whole has
figured out how to
develop an all neural systems that map
directly from
the audio to the transcribes word
transcribed words that were said
and so what really kicked it off was was
the unlocking of
exactly how the neural technology is
going to um
be shoehorned into um
the acoustic model of the
hybrid
automatic speech recognition systems
got it so that's one thing that's always
very interesting to me i don't know a
ton about the inner workings of how all
of these pieces play together
um but it is it is quite interesting to
me as you think about all of the pieces
that have to play nicely together you've
got deep learning and
obviously those neural networks are
doing a lot of the the heavy lifting for
figuring out what these are said and how
all those things work
but it's not just that right i mean
there's so many different bits and
pieces that all kind of play together
the thing that always breaks my head a
little bit is to think that i set a
thing to a device and it was shot off to
the cloud as a recording and then
this whole stack of things happens
it fires it off to some back-end service
to determine how it's going to respond
and all of that happens
a full circuit is under a second uh
that that is the mind-blowing piece to
me because it seems like these things
are possible if i have an hour to
process the data but to do it in such a
tiny amount of time is remarkable
i i agree and
in order to build these assistant
services the
the software engine not just the machine
learning but the software engineering is
is is is wonderfully complex
and in order to you know meet the
expectations of customers there's there
there is a lot of
attention paid to how all these
individual pieces interact and work i
mean just
um just when you ask the device to play
music you know you
um the the device
uh is constantly ready to detect when
you want to use it
and um
the standard way of doing this is called
a wake word and so it depends on your
assistant whether you're saying okay
google hey siri hey sam or you know
mentioning she who must not be named
the the device is constantly ready to
detect this and then once it does it
just sets off the stream of um
of activity
the speech recognizer listens to what
you say
and converts it into a text form
and then it gets sent to
a service that tries to determine you
know what was your intent
um uh and in this case i want to play
some music and
it processes it and tries to figure out
okay what kind of music does he want to
play it should i turn a light on uh
which uh uh which album is this a song
or is this an album so all these
individual pieces interacting the back
end doing the understanding of what it
was what was said
and then once it understands it has to
you know invoke the text to speech
which is alexa's voice
and so
she oh good she didn't hear me and so
you um
um you render what you want the device
to respond with uh verbally and then it
needs a different machine learning
system needs to convert that into audio
and then she comes back and then she
says you know i'm playing songs from
they might be giants on amazon music and
and you're like yeah that's exactly what
i wanted
um once in a while right what's that you
need a little particle man in your life
once in a while right oh yeah yeah
um
yeah triangle man's okay i don't
understand how he ended up in the
garbage can
but uh that's okay maybe you just need a
little self-confidence we could probably
do a full hour on the lyrics if they
might be giants that's for sure
yeah um
yeah so the complexity of the system was
great and that's that's one of the
reasons that i came
to
to amazon i really love the
um the customer focus of the company and
you know the number of customers that
they do have
um and
the
um
the complexity is just wonderful um yeah
we all love solving hard problems it
gives us that rush of endorphin um and
so that's um it's a great place to be so
yeah in summary it's it's complex but
it's a it's a manageable complexity
well that's good because it feels like
an impossibly complex system
uh and when you've got
millions upon millions of people using
it
uh that just adds layers of complexity
right right that's that's amazing well
i wanna i wanna shift focus just a
little bit um first uh i want to
congratulate you i heard you had nine
papers accepted at the interspeech
conference this year that's got to be
some kind of world record
uh i i doubt it and there's some pretty
prolific professors out there sure sure
sure but nine is a lot um and for those
that are watching that may not know a
lot about inner speech can you share
kind of the background on what that
event is and why it's important
right uh so inner speech i think has
been going on for
about 18 years now um it replaced two
older speech conferences that were
kind of interleaved with each other on
odd and even years so it's been going on
in some form and over for for
you know beyond my time as a researcher
um and it's the one conference that's
dedicated entirely to speech
conferencing worldwide with a worldwide
audience
so if you want to know
the latest results of you know how the
different labs are approaching the
problems how they're thinking about it
what kind of results they're getting
um or if you want to publish somewhere
that has uh the broadest possible
exposure to people who are interested in
speech processing in in all of these
aspects
including the things i'm carrying care
about but also for communications and
coding and noise
noise robustness enhancement
inner speeches is my first choice of
conference um to go to that's a that's a
good endorsement
yeah yeah it doesn't
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
mediate that with um
it doesn't have the gravitas of
you know some of the more
premier machine learning conferences
where you'll also see speech papers
but for for the breadth of the audience
and the
the depth of the content it's it's
really it's really tough to beat that's
interesting i can draw a parallel to
that so i spend most of my time talking
to software developers that build for
alexa
and um there are two different
distinctly different types of events
that i go to there are software
development conferences where people are
coming to talk about anything related to
software development and then there are
voice specific conferences and these are
ones that you're going to find all of
the content related to
uh amazon alexa and google and bixby and
all the other services are there and
people are there talking about their
experiences and their knowledge and
their approach
um and it sounds like this this kind of
fits that same model where inner speech
is very very focused on just the speech
aspect of the research
uh where it's in the other bigger more
like you said more notable conferences
those also have a bunch of stuff that
isn't related at all i would imagine
that's right that's right but but then
you know you do get a nice
cross-pollination i i i would i would be
deficient as a scientist and researcher
if i only looked at my vertical i agree
there's a lot of great ideas out there
that can be transplanted
um and science is a fundamentally social
endeavor and probably software is also
has a has a big
component of social very much but
um
if you
if you if you don't write down what
you've done
um you haven't really closed the loop if
you don't communicate it if you don't
participate in that global conversation
um then you're just uh you're doing
yourself in the world a big disservice
and that's why i really believe
there's a there's a famous saying steal
like an artist um but i've often
co-opted that to use like steel like a
software developer i would imagine that
probably works for your stuff as well
it's not necessarily theft but it's uh
it's co-opting an idea that you saw in
some other research and said you know
what that might actually work for the
things that we're trying to do
that's right that's right i think
that's the beauty of the scientific
community is that there is a lot of
knowledge sharing it's uh
while there are times i see that people
try to keep things close to the vest for
uh whatever business purpose in many
cases it's a very open sharing community
which is awesome it is it is and if you
go down the other road you go you know
that the movie trope of the of the mad
scientist they never published right and
they
it just it's just a bad road to go down
i don't do that
uh was was there any key theme that kind
of emerged from this year's event
well
so so like like in previous years
there's a lot of work like the majority
the bulk of it is all about
the
um small changes that makes a positive
improvement the way we we use our
modeling
so this year transformer based models
were really popular so there was a lot
of work about how to apply different
objective functions but how it works on
different data how to different kinds of
conditioning different structures
there's also usually a few threads that
are kind of
oh wow that's interesting this has the
potential to drastically change the way
we're doing things
uh so a few years ago that was something
called rnn transducer rnnt
and the listen spell architectures which
was the first you know attempts at
creating a unified neural architecture
to bring all of speech recognition end
to end under one
one trainable harness
um
recently i think that
um
that thread for me
is representation learning and
unsupervised training
the researchers
have at the at the major labs have been
making really big strides
in
trying to teach our models to learn
learn about the way we communicate with
audio
but do it
the same way humans do um where we're
not we're not giving an explicit
training signals it's just observing and
learning about uh our speech patterns
and that has uh that has a lot of
potential for for for the goals that we
have for as an organization
all right
so i i know one of the papers you have
is called scaling laws for acoustic
models yeah um
and i would imagine as with any any kind
of software
there there are perceived limits to how
things can be done right unreasonable
limits on the size of data or models
right
can you tell us more about that specific
work
yeah uh sure there's so
if you've been if for people who've been
paying attention to machine learning in
the last or deep learning in the last
two or three years
uh there has been a real excitement
in text processing
around building bigger and bigger models
on lots and lots of data
and so we're there
there's companies now creating models
that are orders of magnitude bigger than
anything we would have considered
reasonable
before this this arms race started
but
the thing that interests me
is that before a person builds these
very large models
we don't know
how to properly choose the model size uh
for our data like is it that just bigger
is always better or is there some
diminishing returns
we don't know you know once we choose a
size of the model how much data are we
going to need to train it with
we're kind of blind to that
and so
um
i i believe the default path is just to
experiment and you know try and throw
more parameters and more data and see
what happens
um but i want to enable a more
systematic approach
and with this work i've shown
uh well i demonstrated
that it's possible to experiment with
some small models and small data and
accurately predict how the bigger models
are going to behave
so you can make
you can make more
more intelligent choices
like if you were to
characterize your task and data
you can use this framework to
predict
um
what is the performance of a model
that's unconstrained by data or
parameter count like is the what is the
fundamental limit
of this model architecture on this data
how well can it do
um and that's an interesting question to
answer without actually or get a peek at
without actually you know doing the
effort of creating the large model
yeah
i would imagine it takes a while to
construct and run um
you know significantly larger size
models so that this is a
research time saver at the end of the
day it is it is um yeah and so you can
imagine
reasons why i would want this um
more methodical approach
uh to to doing it is because it does
speed up uh potentially speeds up
experimentation
and and gives you some visibility into
your your hyper parameter space
um
there's a couple of interesting things
to me that also fell out of this
um in addition to like being able to
cheaply design more efficient and more
performant training hyper parameters
you can also use this as as kind of a
language
to compare different model architectures
um so in our field right now
there's a type of model called
transformer and there's type of model
called an lstm
and people will publish a paper and say
the transformers better or they publish
a paper and say the lstm is better
but you can use this kind of
characterization of how does the model
behave
as the data and parameters are scaling
to say things like you know what lstms
are more efficient for a small footprint
and transformers are more efficient for
large large footprint and really
tease that apart so you aren't you're no
longer talking in absolutes but you're
you're making a more reasoned argument
about what's the right tool for the job
yeah
yeah i think
so i'm about to read something from the
page because i want to make sure i get
this right but what i'm going to ask you
to do after i do this we're getting on
to your next paper
is
i'd love for you to explain this in kind
of lay person's terms
uh to our audience because i think
what i'm reading sounds very interesting
but i want to make sure that they
understand it so
your paper proposes that an
attention-based deep learning model
automatically derives optimal syllable
level representation from frame level
and phoneme level audio features now we
spent a decent amount of time here
talking about phonemes and syllables and
how a lot of those pieces fit together
on the software development side
but i'd love to understand the
significance of this work and kind of
what that really means to a user or a
software developer
so
this this work here was was really
driven by my colleague daniel kosekwa
and he
he has a real passion uh for
trying to get our machine learning
models to work
with customers who have atypical speech
that's that might be non-native
stuttered dysarthic
and so he's been using his position as a
scientist and alexa tts
to pursue this passion
i love her
it's interesting of all the software or
hardware i've ever worked on in my
career alexa well echo has
such an opportunity and really has taken
advantage of a lot of it but an
opportunity to really address
accessibility head-on
uh the ways that about you know vision
impaired users
using the device uh they just introduced
a keyboard mode inside the app so that
people that don't have a voice or can't
speak well
uh can type to the device instead and
still get all the interactivity and
things i think it's it's amazing so it's
great to hear that our scientists are
thinking about this too oh right yeah
scientists are thinking about it and
there's there's lots of great projects
bubbling around
you know what are this what are the
simple things we can do um
and we have you know simple mitigations
for um stuttered speech we have
um
for uh
uh for for some class of customers they
they really prefer to have alexa speak
faster and we can do that for them um
there's some really low finding fruit
that are real needle movers for the
people who use these devices um i'm
really proud of the the amount of things
i'm i see inside the company
um to to address these these less
typical customers
uh the
in and so this is this is something
daniel's been pushing so i'll talk about
it as if it you know i might say me or
my but this is really his action project
and so one of the things um
uh that you can do with a computer is
you can you can learn it you can use it
to learn another language
[Music]
but
speech recognition system isn't
sufficient
um to tell you when you're pronouncing
things wrong
uh there's a there's there's a scene
from a classic uh mike myers movie uh a
view to the top
uh where he's
uh his fellow stewardess
um is reading off a card and she's
supposed to say she's supposed to to
next assess the window
but she pushes she puts the wrong stress
on the word assess she puts stress on
the first syllable sure and and says
something entirely different
and so mike says you put the emphasis on
the wrong syllable
and so the speech recognizer would write
down the correct word but you would have
no concept that you set it incorrectly
um and i'll leave it up as an exercise
to the audience to figure out what
exactly this
the
uh so the the key of this work was
beforehand
um there was a very
uh manual and brutal way
of determining
uh automatically determining the stress
pattern that a person uses when they're
speaking
and so
uh the thing that
that daniel did here was
look and see what are the
what are the big guns we can pull out
here
in order to
better
better assess uh the stress pattern that
a person is using
and so he he brought in
the
the attention model
which is a type of machine learning
structure that helps you identify where
in the audio you need to pay attention
to to solve your problem
and he brought in some synthetic data
where he causes the tts system to say
things wrong
and uses that as extra training data
because of course you know data for for
people pronouncing things wrong is is
quite sparse
and ended up getting a really great
result
he asked about the implication to to the
developers
[Music]
so
this type of uh
component
is is most likely going to be
well
let's see it's most likely to be used in
a system for second language learning uh
where a person's improving uh what
they're saying
but it can also be used in um
potentially in um an assistant
stack software stack where
you know automatically it's
understanding that this person is a
second language learner and is maybe
saying things wrong and makes it more
lenient
somehow uh i don't know exactly how that
would work but it's possible but in
terms of the people developing the
skills uh for the assistant it would be
you know just perceived as a higher
success rate among the customers
it raises the question too you said that
the
the speech recognition system
understands the word even if they use
the wrong emphasis yes um but they're
not saying it correctly and it it's
interesting to me to think then um if it
can understand them is it incorrect uh
because
clearly it is managing and uh
more properly
right i certainly understand what you
mean though like if you and i were to
speak and i kept saying emphasis you
would be like no no we need to we need
to fix that
well you know there's there's lots of
dialects in the um and different ways of
speaking even within the
contiguous united states
and
assistants that are serving that
population need to be robust to all the
different ways that people uh people
talk yeah
and
it's it's just much easier if you're
able to either make the system
aware
of the
um
aware of the you know the scope of
things that people might say
the variety of things or to naturally
try and try and bring that down by by
using more
um
i i want to avoid the word standard but
a more popular way of of
speaking okay
uh
one of the other things that you're
working on is the application of large
data and general machine learning
algorithms
and it sounds like a lot of these were
previously kind of hand authored speech
recognition components
which i i can't even imagine required to
hand author a lot of that stuff rather
than leaning on some of the rich machine
learning we have today but
um i'd love for you to give us maybe a
little historical view on how things
have changed since those hand authored
right
right so a few years into my career
let's say
2002 or so
um
we the the the the constituent
components of the the speech recognition
system
where a front end
that generates features from the audio
an
acoustic model
that tries to
represent
tries to classify
each 10 milliseconds of incoming audio
as a speed as one of the known speech
sounds wow
and then an hmm that would try and
string these sounds together
on the order of maybe
15 uh
50 milliseconds
into phones
um like the
uh
this would be about like 43 different
sounds in english
and then a system that
was hand authored by
um linguists
that maps it's like a pronunciation
mapping of all the words that the system
knows
from the lexical forum
into a sequence of phones
and then another system called language
model on top of that that tries to
describe how the words get mapped
together into sentences
and so there was this there was this big
stack the the front end was hand
authored
the
uh the phone set was hand authored the
lexicon the pronunciation dictionary was
hand authored the and and people were
working on these individual systems
trying to make them better and so people
expect you'd specialize in front end
um that one of my first specialties was
in front end trying to
produce acoustic features
that weren't affected by background
noise
and
or you'd specialize in language model or
you specialize in clustering the sounds
together
and so it was just this very big
um
box
full of components and each one
was associated with a black art that you
had to be inducted into in order to
understand what it was and how to
improve it
and
you know about
um
ten years ago
uh again when when
we figured out as a field um i think was
said in you who who did the the first
real big paper on this was they figured
out how the
acoustic model could be a deep learning
system it could be a neural network
and
that
um
that was kind of like the foot in the
door
uh because now um now that you have a
neural network we can start to train
things end-to-end
and so the next step was you know we
instead of mapping to these
c nodes which are the the small pieces
of audio uh labels and then to phones
can we just map to a sequence of phones
directly rather than looking at little
slices of time and trying to label it
can we look at a long piece of time and
say these are the labels and sequence
for that
then that was alex graves he invented
cpc which was a big leap forward there
and so now we have you know the
the hmm and the acoustic model is in in
in the in the in the ditch in in the in
the mix
and then we move to recurrent models
here
and then
uh
the front end gets cons subsumed when um
uh with the wave to vect paper
where
now instead of having a front end that
extracts features we make the end and
model aware of the audio itself the the
individual samples of the audio right
and then with the rnnt and the listen
intend in spell systems we move even
further out and we subsume
the lexicon and the language model into
this end-to-end model
and so now if you're training an rnnt or
or a listen spell model
there's this machine learning framework
inside that's entirely differentiable
entirely trainable
and you just tell it when you hear this
write down this transcription when you
hear this write down this transcription
and you give it a lot of paired data and
it just learns what um it learns what it
needs to do and there's no more
linguists coming up with a
a pronunciation lexicon
you have clustering audio it's just
audio in text out which is which is much
simpler in a way but but we also give up
a lot in terms of configurability sure
now we have a single black box that's
doing the work for us yeah now you're
relying on the blo on the box to be
correct on its own rather than relying
on uh rules and guidance that you've
given it right specifically that's wow
that's interesting
um
man that that's a lot to take because
that uh i mean that sounds like
it probably dramatically affected
people's careers too right you had to
kind of transition i was one of those
black wizards that really understood the
front end really well now i've got to
kind of pivot because that's not as
important anymore that's right um so i
think that this isn't this isn't true of
uh machine learning or speech processing
and specifically this is true
i think
for the for the majority of careers you
might take
um that being agile and and moving
moving with the wave
is is a great strategy
and so in my career i moved from front
end to i actually
took the path of the audio through the
speech recognition system i started out
working on front end and then i went all
the way through to working on the
decoder and the language modeling and
now
now i'm doing end-to-end systems so i
i've been a wizard all the way through
as these different pieces got consumed
yeah the the scope of what i was working
on uh changed
um
but
yeah go ahead no it's okay i was i was
going to continue on here i i uh i have
a follow-up question to that which is
do you imagine a world and i'm going to
ask you some questions about the future
coming up here in just a second but
do you imagine a world where there is
just
the speech recognition system
um or do you think that there will
always be a world in which there are
individual competing efforts at this or
do you think that we will ever get to a
point where it's just like
we should all just use this one
i
generally try not to predict the future
especially in a recorded medium
where they can come back and see how
right or wrong you were um but
uh you're welcome past the question too
if you're no no i'm i'm happy to address
part of it
um
i think that um i'm gonna make an
analogy to the early days of computing
where not everybody could own a computer
because it was so expensive and so
um so unweighty
and today in machine learning uh labs
like open ai are able
to train
you know trillion parameter models for
language modeling
and
i don't think it's the right solution
today
uh for everybody who needs a you know
trillion model parameter to go out and
train one necessarily sure there there's
there's probably a lot of people who
could be well served by borrowing
someone else's
and so when you
so so so in my mind it's a real
trade-off between
you know how much effort is there to
build the thing
and
what is the goodness of sharing what was
built versus
creating a solution for yourself
and over time i think that
the variables that lead into that
decision are going to be shifting
um and we're going to make different
decisions about whether one big
everybody should be using the same model
or everybody should be using specific
models or it makes sense to distribute
or make sense to centralize um in
computing you know where the computing
happened has been shifting over the past
40 years and i think that's the same
thing is going to happen with machine
learning interesting
all right sorry i didn't mean to throw
you that kerbal i just felt like uh that
was the only thing to think about that
we could all just end up unifying on
great question on a model so okay so i
do want to talk to you a little bit
about the future though i mean you've
been in this industry for over two
decades
what is the things that you uh i'm not
calling them predictions but
as you look forward there are things
that you're like man i think we're
actually gonna be we might be able to
accomplish that in the next 10 years are
there things that stand out to you over
the next decade i know i know one that
probably isn't on your list everybody
that i've talked to about this kind of
agrees that sarcasm is really hard
uh and so i won't hold you to talk about
that right
i won't hold you to talk about that
topic but are there other things that
you see that are like i think we may
have some success with this
so
up until now
or
by now i mean plus or minus two years
uh the speech recognition has been about
writing down what a person said
and the
inherent
assumption here
is that the written form contains all
the information we need
but that's not necessarily true
my favorite example is the is the phrase
i love dogs
um if i just say it a neutral tone
it's an isolated it's a fact you can
pick it up if it's if i say i love dogs
um then it's it's understood that i'm
trying to emphasize that that it's me
doing the action if i say i love dogs
i'm i'm i want you to pay attention to
the feelings i have for the dog
and if i say i love dogs
then um you can understand how i feel
about dogs versus you know other other
household pets and so there's this meta
information that we're not getting by
just writing down what was said
and so
you know in the concept of a personal
assistant
i might ask you know to hear
californication and it says shuffling
songs on the album californication
i can say no play the califor
fornication song
and then that's a strong you know
corrective signal to the the device
um that it was about what exactly the
error it was made
um
uh and that's different from play the
californication song
um which is you know an indication that
maybe they played the wrong song or the
wrong album yeah so so that kind of meta
information is getting more into the
mind and the intent of the person doing
the talking
and
um you know maybe
that is the first step to solving
sarcasm too uh but but we use speech
as humans as a way to you know have a
meeting of the minds and understand each
other and you know have these mirror
neurons you know firing and
understanding and getting in
conversation
but that's really missing from the way
we're interacting with computers because
the only thing
uh if it's a straight up speech
recognition system the only thing it
knows about is is the text of the words
that you said right
and so that's that's what i think would
be a great advance in the next decade
i i like that though i mean that i love
dog sentence is so simple and concise
but it really does have so many
different meanings
uh based entirely on how you say it not
what you say
that's a great example
uh all right so we we are wrapping up
here we only have a few minutes left one
of the things that i'd love for you to
offer any kind of guidance you have to
people that are thinking about getting
into a research career specifically at
amazon
um
do you have any guidance or advice you
can offer to folks
uh yeah i'd happen to the um
so i i i i'm going to share some things
from my experience i'm not telling
people exactly what to do with their
lives
this has just been things that are
generally true for me
a general piece of the career advice i
give to people when they ask
is be open to opportunity
it's natural once you start down a path
to continue to follow it and that's
really good because it causes you to
think about your problem space more
deeply it allows you to develop better
solutions over time and this is exactly
what
your master's or a phd program does for
you allows you to think deeply about a
problem
undistracted for a few years
um but it's really important to balance
that with stepping back and looking
around to see is there something else
you should be doing is there an
opportunity here that i'm missing
um and i personally if i stayed on track
in my career i would still be developing
algorithms for printheads
in in spokane washington i would have
missed the opportunity to go to graduate
school
the opportunity with microsoft research
was a diversion an opportunity that i i
grabbed up
the opportunity to join amazon was
another one where i stepped back my you
know my computer broke um i was on
vacation in hawaii so i was literally
unable to log in for two weeks and i
thought about it and i'm like you know
what i step back look and see you know
it's time to ch it's time for a change
um
and it allows you to execute on projects
that you know aren't directly in your
line of sight so that balance i think is
really important
specifically for speech recognition
signal processing and which i guess this
applies to all the machine learning look
for an important problem that no one
solved
can we make humans but can we make
machines learn language the way that
humans do
can we tie the speech recognition and
speech understanding more closely
together
um or more broadly if you can find
something that the entire field is
currently overlooking that's super
impactful some assumption we're making
that needs to be changed some some new
way of doing things that
that is a
recipe for success that's what you know
dan povey did
when he created the caldi system
and specifically to amazon
come to amazon if you're passionate
about customer obsessed science
um
amazon strives uh they say this all time
internally to be the world's most
customer obsessed company on the planet
um everything that amazon does is in
service of the customer and the science
that we do is applied scientists shares
that sentiment
the company is happy to invest in
long-term projects short-term projects
risky projects risk-adverse projects but
there's one thing they all have in
common is that when we start out we know
what success looks like and success is
making something better for our
customers
and so that's um that that really speaks
to me um i was trained as an engineer
and i was trained as an engineer as an
undergrad and i saw that engineering
mindset i want to build things and i
build things because i want to build
things for people right and and i found
amazon to be a great place to do that i
agree i think that there's nothing more
refreshing than being able to sit in any
meeting
and have the defensible position to be
able to say i'm doing this because of
our customers doing this to solve this
problem for our customers you can say
it's too expensive or too hard or
whatever and that's fine but at the end
of the day this is something that we
need to do for in the best interest of
our customers and uh that's an
incredibly strong position to hide
behind
uh with anything in amazon
yes absolutely absolutely all right well
josh i want to thank you so much for
being here today uh you have taught me
plenty about some of the inner workings
of our systems and certainly some of the
research that's gone into a lot of those
things so i want to first thank you so
much for being here today
for our audience i want to make sure
that you guys have an opportunity to
check out amazon.science if you haven't
been there you can find lots of
published papers including several from
yasha uh and i would also encourage you
guys to check out the inner speech 2021
conference where as we mentioned uh yesh
is going to be presenting nine different
papers
it should give you a flavor for kind of
the work we do here
on the alexa ai team
and you can always learn about science
to see the latest research techniques
and youtube videos and all sorts of cool
stuff there so um yasha again thank you
so much for being here i'm going to end
us with showing a quick video that's
talking about meeting the scientists
that work at uh amazon and alexa so
we'll sign thanks so much for being here
jeff it's been a pleasure uh thank you
for the conversation i i really enjoyed
it and uh thanks for everybody for
watching it's been great to uh great to
talk today
thank you thank you everybody for tuning
in we'll see you next time
my name is ola banji shonibar i am an
applied scientist at amazon i work with
the pro language understanding service
and response team within alex's speech
my name is aparna and i'm a senior
applied scientist in the alexa speech
recognition team currently i'm working
on building better experiences for
bilingual customers of alexa just like
myself my name is venky i'm an applied
science manager in alexa ai me and my
team of scientists work on different
paralinguistic signals associated with
voice as we know alexa is used by many
customers across languages across age
groups with different types of voices we
make sure we understand everyone
irrespective of their variance in their
works
i'm lorenzo i'm an apply science manager
in the alexa test for speech research
team i joined the team three years ago
with a task to improve the explosivity
and naturalness of our scientific voices
and this resulted in the release of the
emotional capabilities for alexa
currently i am working with many other
teams trying to push forward the
envelope of what we can do with our
technology i'm kayoko i'm a senior
speech scientist in the texas speech
team at amazon i joined amazon five
years ago and initially worked on the
launch of amazon's first japanese texas
speech voice in the poli service
followed by the launch of the japanese
alexa and more recently i've worked on
the launch of bilingual alexa making the
american english alexa voice speak
spanish buenos dias
[Music]
i get to work on problems that are not
well defined you will be expected to
develop and deliver end-to-end solutions
you would work on problems that are
unstructured and then depending on the
level
you might be expected to mentor engineer
colleague as well one of the things that
anyone will notice when they work in
alexa ai
is the amazing group of scientists and
engineers that we have around here so
there's lots to learn of the last two
years i've learned quite a bit it's
helped me become a better scientist a
better thinker and a better employee we
are constantly learning new things so we
are having to adapt and adopt new
technologies not only that we are
keeping learning we are keeping
absorbing technologies from other fields
such as nlp or computer vision there is
always a chance to learn new things so i
have never bought many of the problems
that i worked on did not have any prior
research work on it or very little of it
there are also problems on which there's
plenty of research available but many
times the work done on academic data
sets doesn't really translate when we
work on solving these problems but likes
our customers i really enjoy the
challenge of working on and solving
these problems and this is really what
makes innovation at the heart of what we
do at alexa nowadays more and more
machine learning techniques are being
applied across different domains and in
texas speech we're using a lot of
approaches developed outside of the
speech domain which means that we see a
lot of researchers with completely
different backgrounds joining us in tts
the customers
they are placed at the forefront of
every decision we make and so if there
is any character or skill you think that
would enable you to be customer obsessed
that's a plus one alex is a fantastic
place for anyone who wants to work on
solving real-world practical problems
with deep learning in the speech and
natural language understanding space
there's plenty of opportunity to
innovate and build state of the art
solutions for some of these problems
[Music]